bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver notre
grand témoin ce soir préside le groupe
horizon à l'Assemblée Laurent marquant
j'ai dit bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
le parti d'Édouard Philippe bien sûr
horizon tient son congrès ce weekend on
va en parler l'ancien Premier ministre
qui plaît aussi pour une coalition avec
les républicains pour sortir de la crise
loyale mais libre est-ce que c'est
tenable et pour combien de temps on en
parle tout à l'heure mais on commence
évidemment avec la neuvième journée
d'action contre la réforme des retraites
pointées du doigt par Emmanuel Macron
les syndicats exaspérés ont réussi à
nouveau à rassembler massivement on va
faire le point sur l'ampleur du
mouvement et sur les secteurs en grève
des débordements ont été constatés dans
beaucoup de villes de France scène
chaotique à Paris ce soir la crainte
d'une flambée de violence et dans tous
les esprits grands débats dans un
instant avec nos invités sur ce plateau
avant de retrouver bien sûr à 20h15 les
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée vous me suivez ça
vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
le gouvernement comptait sur un
essoufflement et bien c'est raté
l'interview d'Emmanuel Macron hier a
manifestement gonflé les rangs des
manifestants contre la réforme des
retraites on va faire le point ce soir
sur cette 9e journée de mobilisation qui
sont dégénérés globalement a été
émaillée dans beaucoup de villes de
France par des violences bonsoir Antoine
Armand bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes député renaissance de
Haute-Savoie bonsoir Jérôme Guedj vous
vous retrouvez député socialiste de
l'Essonne vous étiez dans le cortège
parisien cet après-midi vous nous direz
ce que vous avez compris ce que vous
avez senti de l'état d'esprit des
manifestants tout comme vous Sophie
Binet bonsoir vous avez défilé
aujourd'hui secrétaire général de la CGT
cadre l'Inter syndical qui se réunit en
ce moment même pour décider de la suite
si vous êtes au courant déjà de la
décision n'hésitez pas à nous la donner
enfin bonsoir Jean-François Mathieu
bienvenue vous êtes sociologue
spécialiste des mouvements sociaux vous
nous direz si on a basculé ou pas dans
ce qu'on appelle maintenant la
radicalisation Laurent marquant jelly
bien sûr vous êtes bienvenue dans ce
débat votre regard nous nous intéressent
n'hésitez pas à intervenir on commence
avec le billet de Stéphane blackovski
l'ampleur du mouvement les chiffres les
images le chrono de Blacko c'est parti
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes et tous alors 9e journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui en France et
donc neuvième chronique pour moi sur le
bilan de la mobilisation donc vous
commencez à connaître un petit peu la
routine on commence normalement par les
chiffres de la mobilisation mais depuis
le temps on a appris que les chiffres
qui avaient des grosses querelles à ce
propos donc l'exemple qu'on ressort
c'est Marseille aujourd'hui la police a
compté 16000 manifestants à Marseille
tandis que la CGT en a compté 17 fois
plus
280000 bon c'est évidemment le cas
extrême mais je veux dire au-delà de la
querelle de chiffres je crois que ce
qu'on veut savoir aujourd'hui c'est le
choix entre deux mots finalement est-ce
qu'il y a eu aujourd'hui un record de
mobilisation ou est-ce qu'il y a eu un
regain de mobilisation alors oui il y a
eu record même la police le reconnaît à
Paris jamais autant de manifestants en
revanche selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur au niveau national on n'a
pas battu de record donc record ou pas
on pourra en discuter mais une chose qui
est incontestable c'est qu'il y a eu un
vrai regain de mobilisation par rapport
à la dernière journée qui était
organisée
le 15 mars en tout cas il y a un retour
qui a été battu
personne le bon test c'est celui du
nombre de policiers mobilisés plus de
12000 du jamais vu de depuis le début du
mouvement donc évidemment depuis kalizac
dead borne a utilisé le 49-3 on a vu que
dès le soir même il y a eu des incidents
à la Concorde qui depuis quelques jours
se
reproduisent chaque soir en France et
donc ça finalement contaminé un peu
cette 9e journée de mobilisation il y a
eu des affrontements à Rennes au milieu
de la journée il y a des attentats assez
fort et un policier blessé à Paris et
des affrontements qui continuent donc ça
c'est quelques images on va pas en
rajouter sur ce qui se passe en ce
moment à Paris donc ce qui fait la
différence de cette 9e journée sont
c'est ce climat beaucoup plus dur et
puis aussi une mobilisation des jeunes
qu'on a pu remarquer c'est anecdotique
mais révélateur à ça ce qui est réputé
avec la fac de droite à Paris a été
bloqué quelques temps je crois que ça
n'était pas arrivé depuis une
cinquantaine d'années donc résultat on
interroge là aussi c'est classique les
leaders syndicaux au début du cortège
avant de se mettre en marche à côté CGT
ce matin j'entendais que les
représentants refusaient de condamner
officiellement la violence en disant que
c'était la justice qui devait condamner
donc Philippe Martinez lui il pense
qu'un durcissement c'est une manière de
faire plier le gouvernement à l'écoute
aujourd'hui pour la première fois depuis
deux mois c'est la plus grosse baisse de
production d'électricité en France moins
22000 mégawatts ça veut dire qu'il y a
des grévistes les poubelles il y en a
encore dans les rues malgré les
réquisitions scandaleuses il y en a
encore dans les rues et il y a plein de
grève tandis que côté Laurent Berger
sans trop de surprise non plus non pas
qu'on soit contre le durcissement mais
on s'inquiète un peu à l'idée que ça
durcissement et notamment s'il y a des
rattrapages finissent par couper le
mouvant le pignon en l'écoute les
Français ils aimeraient bien je crois
que tout ça s'apaise mais ils le disent
pas on pointant les responsables des
organisations syndicales il pense que il
y a une responsabilité du gouvernement à
régler cette situation sociale
donc ils ne sont pas d'accord surtout
sur le savait mais jusqu'à présent ils
ont toujours rester unis donc on attend
la décision de l'interseyndicale mais je
ne crois pas que on va diviser ce soir
les deux syndicats ça c'est le côté
syndicat côté politique ben on sait que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est souvent à
Marseille à chaque fois mobilisation ce
matin on l'a interrogé sur les dérapages
violents qu'on avait constaté dans
plusieurs villes de France voilà sa
réponse
je voudrais dire contre tous ceux qui
font des gargarismes sur la violence
qu'il n'y a pas de violence dans les
mouvements que nous sommes en train de
vivre qu'il y a eu ici quatre ou cinq
poubelles qui brûlent n'est rien du tout
à côté de ce qu'on a vu dans le passé
alors le résultat c'est que en attendant
ça il y a un syndicaliste qui était très
fâché mais pas très étonnant parce que
ce syndicaliste c'est le secrétaire
général des syndicats de police qu'ils
appellent David lemars donc il était
interviewé sur Radio Classique ce matin
il a sévèrement condamné le propos de
Mélenchon en disant qu'il lui reprochait
de vouloir monter les Français contre la
police mais moi ce qui m'a le plus
surprise ce matin dans ses propos à
David lemartre c'est que à peine couvert
il s'en prenait aussi à Emmanuel Macron
en disant que cette manière de gérer la
crise lui rappelait lui policier le la
manière dont on avait géré le mouvement
des gilets jaunes je vous laisse écouter
avec la relance de Guillaume Durand qui
verra pas à l'intervention de guerre
d'Emmanuel Macron on écoute
je vais revenir à 2018-2019 s'il y en a
qui croient dans ce pays que une crise
sociale ça se résout par le maintien de
l'ordre ou par l'usage de la force de la
police face à une foule c'est pas comme
ça qu'on sort d'une crise sociale donc
il manque hier un signe d'apaisement qui
vous aurait aidé à faire votre boulot
c'est ça que vous pensez c'est pas ce
que je peux penser parce que j'ai pas le
droit de prendre une parole politique en
représentant les commissaires de police
mais ce que je pensais c'est que la
police est souvent mise à contribution
dans des crises qui s'accumulent alors
il a pas le droit de le dire bon nous
peut-être qu'on peut quand même faire
cette remarque c'est-à-dire que hier le
président a dit en dénonçant les
factieux et les factions cet usage du
mot factieux effectivement ça fait tout
à fait penser à la crise des gilets
jaunes puissent regarder vous souvenez
peut-être de Benjamin Griveaux et bien
c'est le mot qui l'employait quand il
parlait des gilets jaunes en disant
voilà ce sont des factieux donc je vous
laisse débattre mais malgré tout il me
semble que là après la crise des gilets
jaunes le président de la République je
vais mettre au point une nouvelle
méthode vous allez voir ça sera plus
comme ça jusqu'à présent et puis là
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
repartir sur une crise type gilet jaune
il y a beaucoup de choses dans votre
billet ce soir merci beaucoup
Stéphane je vous donne juste les
chiffres qu'on a eu il y a quelques
minutes au niveau national pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur un peu plus
d'un million de manifestants aujourd'hui
dans le pays pour la CGT 3 millions et
demi on va y revenir Antoine Armand dans
le cortège on entendait beaucoup il
devait apaiser il a embrasé après
l'interview du président hier est-ce que
vous prenez une part de responsabilité
dans ce qui se passe dans le pays
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut quand
même faire la différence et c'est pour
le bien commun entre deux choses qui
n'ont rien à voir
la très grande majorité des manifestants
aujourd'hui l'ont fait dans le calme
dans l'expression de leurs droits le
plus strict qui est l'expression d'un
mécontentement sur une réforme qui n'est
pas populaire et puis il y a des
blocages des tentatives d'intimidation
des expressions violentes verbalement ou
physiquement qui sont parfaitement
condamnables mais vous pensez que c'est
indispensable totalement la distinction
comment dire imperméable c'est de monde
là la colère elle peut basculer dans la
révolte que l'expression du président de
la République à l'issue de l'adoption de
la réforme des retraites qui est
contestée par les manifestants qui
manifestent aujourd'hui n'est pas
contenté les manifestants pardon mais ça
n'a rien d'extraordinaire la question
n'est pas celle-là la question est
peut-on continuer dans notre pays à
manifester librement sereinement sans se
livrer à des blocages sans se livrer à
des factions qui n'ont rien à voir à
nouveau avec l'écrasante majorité des
manifestants aujourd'hui c'est la
question qui se pose pour factieux ce
sont les casseurs c'est ça évidemment ce
sont les casseurs mais je crois qu'ils
peuvent le dire aussi
je le dis simplement les bloqueurs ce
sont aussi ceux qui coupent
l'électricité des élus qui viennent les
intimider pour leur vote ou pour leur
prise de position Jérôme Guedj vous
étiez dans les cortèges qu'est-ce que
vous avez senti et est-ce que l'élu
socialistes que vous êtes a presque on a
vu comme ça notamment à Paris appelle au
calme ce soir moi à Paris cet après-midi
j'ai passé du temps presque 4 heures
j'ai vu comment la qualifier une foule
légitime voilà et j'utilise à dessin à
l'expression parce que les deux termes
ont été galvaudés par le Président de la
République la foule le peuple qui se met
en mouvement c'est pas les factieux et
c'est à dessin le président de la
République est trop lettrés et c'est
trop ciselé ses propos pour ne pas
l'avoir fait à dessin précisément quand
hier dans la même formulation il parle
des factieux et des factions c'est la
même chose
il est dans une logique de provocation
quand il dans la même phrase alors on va
me dire il y a eu le service après-vente
derrière en disant mais non il faisait
pas de comparaison mais dans la même
phrase il mentionne ceux qui ont marché
sur le Capitole les soutiens
suprémacistes de Donald Trump ou
l'extrême droite de bolsonaro c'est tout
sauf de l'apaisement l'interview d'hier
parlez-nous du cortège est-ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'on est en train de
basculer dans autre chose depuis
aujourd'hui j'ai vu une force tranquille
une foule avec une détermination plutôt
joyeuse une jeunesse que j'étais
contente de voir de voir en nombre et
puis je surtout j'ai vu j'ai vu beaucoup
beaucoup de monde alors je veux pas moi
participer à la polémique mais on voit
bien que là il y a de la fébrilité
c'était censé apaiser et donc là comme
c'est un échec voilà c'est un échec il
tablé sur la résignation il le tablé sur
une forme d'épuisement de lassitude il y
a plus de monde parce que les gens
continuent à penser que la réforme elle
est injuste socialement mais que en plus
a été rajouté la brutalité démocratique
il y a eu une sorte de de renouveau de
de remobilisation avec le déclenchement
du 49-3 et la motion de censure dans les
conditions dans lesquelles on l'a vu
donc voilà il faut que ça continue faut
que ça vous allez nous dire ce que vous
en pensez mais quand même ce soir malgré
tout il y a peut-être un regain voire un
record vous nous allez nous le dire mais
elle est plus pacifique cette
manifestation on a pris on a fait
promener le micro dans le cortège
parisien on a demandé à deux
manifestants au fond est-ce que la
violence à ce stade du bras de fer
est-ce que c'est la solution écoutez je
pense qu'il y a une très grande colère
et qu'elle s'exprime à travers ces
mouvements qui sont plus radicaux et
plus violents et moi j'en fais pas
partie mais je pense qu'ils ont un rôle
à jouer ils sont une expression de cette
colère que nous ressentons tous mais les
violences même si on est contre enfin
moi je cautionne pas mais je ferme les
yeux quand même c'est un déni mais à un
moment on fait quand le gouvernement ils
sont dans un déni on y est on est aussi
à un moment la seule façon de faire
avancer les choses c'est de se faire
entendre et les manifestations
pacifiques ça fonctionne peut-être j'en
sais rien j'ai pas vu de mon vécu mais
les violences il y a toujours une petite
partie d'extrémiste qui font malgré tout
même si on les aime pas c'est les choses
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça Sophie
Binet ce que je réponds d'abord c'est
que aujourd'hui on a battu tous les
records des records historiques
c'est-à-dire déjà le 7 mars c'était très
élevé et c'était les manifestations les
plus importantes depuis 1945 là on est
au-dessus du 7 mars donc je pense qu'il
faut vraiment qu'Emmanuel Macron
sorte un petit peu de l'Elysée les
députés
en Grèce on l'a noté mais il y avait
plus de gens dans la rue en termes ah
oui en terme de manifestation oui
c'était très net dans toutes les villes
de France et notamment à Paris et en
termes de grève oui on a franchi un cap
dans les grèves parce que le 49-3 ça a
été un électrochoc et puis
l'intervention du président en rajoute
encore et l'immense majorité de ces
mobilisations sont pacifiques moi
j'étais aussi pendant 4 heures dans le
cortège parisien c'était une
manifestation pacifique déterminée avec
des gens qui sont là pour obtenir le
retrait de la référence
en gros on a rien obtenu donc avec la
violence on y arrivera c'est un petit
peu ce qui s'est passé avec les le
gouvernement avait cédé pourquoi ce soir
Philippe Martinez n'appelle pas comme
Laurent Berger au calme mais parce qu'en
fait l'état d'esprit de tout le monde
c'est on n'est pas là pour faire le
service après-vente des provocations du
pouvoir c'est Emmanuel Macron qui dans
toutes ses interventions
mais le feu fait de la provocation en
refusant d'entendre ce qui se passe en
refusant d'entendre que depuis deux mois
nous nous mobilisons de façon pacifique
avec un mot d'ordre clair c'est à dire
le retrait de cette réforme des
retraites il refuse d'entendre et
forcément la colère elle monte et en
refusant d'entendre ce qui est très
grave c'est qu'en fait il installe
l'idée selon laquelle quand on se
mobilise pacifiquement ça ne sert à rien
nous évidemment on ne pense pas ça comme
organisation syndicale nous nos modes
d'action sont pacifiques
contre les personnes toujours par
principe bien sûr mais en attendant
aujourd'hui ce que nous voyons c'est des
violences de plus en plus importantes du
pouvoir une répression très importante
il y a eu des centaines de garde à vue
injustifiées dénoncé même par les forces
de l'or par les Français
consacrée etc il y a des réquisitions de
grévistes qui sont inacceptables et il y
a aussi des entreprises qui organisent
des locks out pour contourner le droit
de grève et donc qui déclare des
fermetures administratives comme ça
elles forcent les salariés à prendre
leur congés et elles les empêche de
faire grève c'est par exemple le cas de
Legrand une entreprise du CAC 40 qui est
en train de mettre en place un
darkema pareil qui ont fait ça qui est
totalement illégal donc là on voit une
répression qui est en train de se
généraliser dans un contexte où il y a
un 49-3 et qu'on passe en force un
projet c'est pas du tout un baroud
d'honneur un soir ça va continuer le
bras de fer continue selon nos confrères
de LCI l'intercy syndicale vient de
décider d'une nouvelle mobilisation
mardi prochain le 28 mars prochain
Jean-François à Mathieu est-ce qu'on est
en train de changer de nature dans la
mobilisation est-ce que vous voyez à
l'oeuvre une sorte d'avant après 49-3
oui bien sûr tout le monde l'a constaté
avec une montée depuis jeudi jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et évidemment ça va
continuer on a tendance à oublier que on
vient de connaître deux mois d'une
extraordinaire tranquillité dans les
manifestations et je rappelle que depuis
2016 on s'était habitués à autre chose
que ce soit pendant la loi travail ou
pendant les gilets jaunes etc donc on
avait oublié tout ça au début c'était
presque surprenant d'ailleurs mais un
calme absolument extraordinaire comment
on pouvait on peut expliquer le
gouvernement des 1500 casseurs ce soir à
Paris il n'était pas là manifestement
avant ce sont que des casseurs où ce
sont des gens plus en colère qui
décident de devenir violent mais il y
avait 800 000 manifestants 800 000
manifestants 1500 casseurs faire le
ratio aussi c'est toujours c'est
toujours comme Jérôme
les jeunes étaient désormais un peu plus
présents c'est ce qu'on a observé depuis
jeudi c'est vrai qu'avant ils étaient
vraiment aux abonnés absents c'est moins
vrai et naturellement quand vous avez
beaucoup de jeunes
qui sont dans la rue et qui sont
militants qui sont proches de certaines
organisations
quand vous êtes en révolution permanente
onpa quand vous êtes dans la mouvance je
dirais plus largement
d'extrême gauche ou anarchiste oui
forcément vous avez des proximités vous
avez bon après du côté syndical on sait
que il faut faire une distinction qui
est très importante parce que je vois
qu'elle était abordée tout à l'heure et
elle est peut-être au cœur du débat
quand
Martinez parle de durcissement
en réalité bien entendu ils vise des
formes d'action qui sont classiques dans
le monde syndical depuis la nuit des
temps y compris bien sûr à la CGT dans
certaines fédérations qui sont pas
forcément bloquer le courant des
parlementaires mais qui peuvent être
naturellement des opérations qu'on
appelle coup de poing des opérations
dites de piquets de grève de blocage etc
mais dans les raffineries oui je sais
routieres mais si vous voulez quand vous
prenez l'histoire des grèves depuis le
19e siècle il en a toujours été ainsi
c'est même relativement admis et
habituel dans à la fois les entreprises
dans la vie des relations sociales et
des conflits du travail tout le monde le
sait c'est jamais un monde dans lequel
les choses se passent dans le respect
absolument scrupuleux de de la loi à
chaque fois vous voyez il y a pas un
droit ouvert à ni à la barricade ni à la
poubelle enflammée ni au blocage quel
qu'il soit d'une route par exemple mais
au bout d'un rond-point mais tout le
monde sait que c'est comme ça dans les
mouvements sociaux et voilà donc cette
distinction jamais importante après
évidemment tout tout ce que qu'il
importe de faire c'est faire la
distinction dans les types de violence
la distinction de l'homme et de la
fonction évidemment un point important
les personnes et c'est là à mon avis que
porte le point principal et c'est vrai
qu'on pourrait s'attendre parfois de
certains responsables politiques le font
pas de bien indiquer que cette limite ou
de rappeler que cette limite ne doit
jamais être franchie qui s'agisse du
parlementaire de du patron d'entreprise
du ou de du policier l'homme et la
fonction c'est un point qui est enfin
moi je pense que c'est un point
important dans les mouvements sociaux
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet ce soir
est-ce que ça pourrait mal tourner on
entend dire attention
aussi bien côté force de l'ordre la
bavure policière que dans les
manifestants ce que est-ce que c'est
l'inquiétude qui vous habite ce soir
mais forcément inquiet lorsqu'on voit
des images de violence lorsqu'on voit
des policiers qui chargent des jeunes
qui
veulent aller se battre
quand on voit quelques dérives on est
inquiet mais je voudrais quand même
rappeler je vais le faire à mon tour je
vais faire une distinction vous avez
depuis le début de la contestation
contre la réforme des retraites des
manifestants qui sont soit syndiqués
soit ils ne le sont pas et qui
manifestent dans le calme et il faut les
respecter ensuite vous avez il est vrai
et on le voit depuis un certain nombre
d'années dans les mouvements sociaux et
les manifestations en France mais
ailleurs ça tombe de personnes qui ne
sont pas là forcément pour manifester
pacifiquement mais plutôt pour être dans
une confrontation avec l'ordre établi
avec le pouvoir avec l'autorité et en
cela cela représente à mes yeux une
inquiétude est-ce que vous répondez au
jeune homme qui dit très clairement au
fond il nous permettent d'aller plus
vite ils nous permettent d'obtenir ce
qu'on n'arrive pas à obtenir dans le
calme c'est la contradiction avec le
principe de démocratie
c'est à dire que c'est par la violence
qu'on impose à un moment un ordre et pas
par la voie démocratique et alors cela
ce n'est pas le modèle de société vers
lequel je me suis tourné vers lequel je
pense nous sommes tournés il y a quand
même deux élus ici qu'est-ce que vous
demandez comment on en sort on a
l'impression un peu que vous jouez un
peu la division 3 élus pardonnez-moi au
fond c'est ça vous attendez que
l'opinion finisse par dire c'est un
supportable il faut revenir à l'ordre
contre le chaos c'est ça que vous jouez
la partition pas du tout mais d'abord
quand vous avez des collègues
parlementaires qui insulte des ministres
ou qui jouent soi-disant pour des
raisons d'agit propre à la décapitation
que vous avez d'autre part des
responsables syndicaux qui continuent de
croire que c'est une question piège de
condamner les violences parce que ce que
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure est quand
même préoccupant on peut tout à fait
condamner madame les violences sans
discrédibiliser
ce n'est pas un piège est-ce qu'on peut
viser le pays qui soutient la réforme
qui soutient à l'opposition pas du tout
écouter je suis désolé de le rappeler à
nouveau je pense que c'est important il
y a eu un examen de ce texte à
l'Assemblée nationale qui a été empêché
en travée perturbé bloquer sa beauté par
des milliers d'amendements d'un seul
groupe politique puisque les autres
groupes politiques de l'opposition les
ont une fininés il y a eu non je parle
des insoumis puisque le parc socialiste
Europe Écologie Les Verts le
Parti communiste le groupe JDR ont
retiré en pour que on avance et qu'on
ait un débat sur le vote il y a eu un
examen au Sénat il y a une commission
mixte paritaire ce texte a été adopté au
Sénat la motion de censure qui a suivi
le 49-3 qui était une motion de censure
composite pour être aimable entre à peu
près toutes les oppositions qui
n'avaient à peu près rien au commun a
été repoussé donc quand on dit tout à
l'heure comme Monsieur Guedj avec
justement l'aspect lettré aussi des
choses que la manifestation est légitime
le Parlement n'est pas légitime le
processus le processus institutionnel
qui a été n'est pas légitime vous me
posez une question je vais vous répondre
à un moment donné l'accumulation des
outils de cadenassage du débat
parlementaire voyez-vous vous et moi à
aucun moment été appelé à se prononcer
sur le texte et pourquoi aucun moment
non attendez non vous pouvez chercher
toutes les responsabilités vous avez
voulu limiter dans le temps mais vous
savez quoi regardez vous allez échouer
de la même manière que vous avez échoué
à dans la fameuse pédagogie à expliquer
que la réforme a été juste et qu'elle
était indispensable de la même manière
vous allez échouer à expliquer que vous
l'avez adopté dans des conditions
démocratiques la preuve c'est que la
réponse ça a été un sursaut de
participation depuis que vous avez
recouru aux 49-3 le vrai panache aurait
consisté à mettre cette réforme au vote
le jeudi concerné et de voir ce que le
les parlementaires voté si elle passait
elle serait passée le vote et en
coulisses tous on aurait préféré le vote
clairement tout parlementaire souhaite
aller au vote maintenant est-ce que on a
les jouets l'avenir du système de
répartition à la loterie de quelques
élus
c'est pas parce que vous dites que vous
me croyez pas que ça devient intéressant
non mais alors les économistes les
sondages moi je je retraite non mais on
va pas refaire
du régime des retraites
la situation actuelle si le texte avait
été rejeté après tout est-ce que c'était
pas préférable politiquement ou même
avec peut-être adopter d'une voix est-ce
que voilà c'est rétrospectivant vous
avez fait le bon choix avec le 49-3 mais
écoutez le choix était très clair donc
le président de la République avait pris
l'engagement dans sa campagne de faire
cette réforme cette réforme elle a été
soumise à concertation les organisations
syndicales ont dès le début marqué une
opposition c'est leur droit le plus
stricte à tout relèvement de l'âge légal
ensuite il y a eu une concertation
parlementaire il y a eu un examen du
texte il a été adopté dans des
conditions institutionnelles et je
regrette de vous le dire démocratique
parce que quand vous dites que ce n'est
pas démocratique qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire monsieur Guedj vous voulez
dire que vous voulez dire que le
processus institutionnel qui est encadré
par la discussion n'est pas démocratique
vous voulez dire que ce sont on peut
avoir le débat mais si vous voulez
l'égalité légitimité mais à un moment
donné quand on est sur quelque chose qui
a ce point fracture le pays et quand on
est le président de la République garant
des institutions à un moment il faut
avoir un peu de Vista et comprendre que
cette espèce d'endettement à vouloir
avoir raison tout seul parce que le vrai
drame il est là c'est l'opinion publique
qui compte c'est l'ensemble des
syndicats qui sont contre c'est le
Parlement dans lequel vous n'avez pas
réussi à construire une majorité donc à
la fin c'est quoi c'est Emmanuel qui
discute avec Macron et et qui décide
tout seul parce que ça psyché sur
détermine tout le reste et qu'il faut
on se fait jamais un jour à soi-même en
tenant compte du contexte politique du
contexte social et donc pour répondre à
la question comment on en sort on en
sort forcément par le retrait de la
réforme aujourd'hui je vois pas
autrement parce que là tel qu'il se
partie la mobilisation elle va aller
crescendo et je reviens sur des
violences parce que je veux pas qu'elle
l'accapare le débat je dis quand même ne
jouez pas avec le feu
jouez pas avec le feu moi j'ai aucun
problème à condamner les violences c'est
bien physique dans quelques mouvements
politiques ou social que ce soit mais de
la même manière on a vu un durcissement
des conditions d'intervention du
maintien de l'ordre on n'a pas vu
précédemment allez ça je peux vous dire
parce que
la transition est comptée pompier
pompier pyromane avec cette idée de se
dire il faut jouer l'ordre contre la
mobilisation sociale avec ces images de
d'incendie qui sont plus nombreuses sur
les écrans que la mobilisation sereine
tranquille familiale qu'on a vu ces
jours-ci la stratégie du maintien de
l'ordre est donc en question surtout
depuis les centaines d'interpellations
ces derniers jours le préfet de police
de Paris Laurent Nunez se défend de tout
arrestation préventive pour empêcher les
manifestations on va faire le point
d'abord avec Marion Becker et puis la
parole à vous juste après
et des policiers directement visé par
les casseurs et les manifestants les
plus radicaux
[Applaudissements]
à coups de projectiles et de pétards au
milieu des incendies
dans le cortège elle les manifestants
eux et dénoncent des réactions en
disproportionnées et des violences
policières pour l'avoir vécu le samedi
surtout le retour de la brave était
assez impressionnant assez terrifiant et
au-delà du routeur de votre ministère
c'est tout un système qui pousse
vraiment à l'affrontement et qui est
assez tendu quand on a assez pacifiste
et c'est vrai que enfin eux bah c'est
une brigade de répression du coup bah
enfin ils ont pas de véhicule pour nous
interpeller et nous emmener je sais pas
ou quoi par exemple du coup c'était
vraiment de la répression pure et dure
et bref allez esquiver les coups de
Matra qui devait enfin qu'ils voulaient
envoyer sur les réseaux sociaux et des
vidéos suscite la polémique comme cette
intervention musclée un policier frappe
un homme au visage il s'effondre à
sommet
la police des polices a été saisie après
la diffusion de ces images mardi le
ministre de l'Intérieur a fait un rappel
à l'ordre évidemment si les policiers
ont commis des actes contraires la
déontologie ils seront sanctionnés comme
je le fais depuis que je suis ministre
de l'Intérieur ces interventions postent
une autre question lundi près de 300
personnes ont été interpellées à Paris
et placés en garde à vue pour les
avocats ces arrestations massives sont
une façon d'entraver les manifestations
là il y a une politique pénale de la
police et du parquet qui consiste à
interpeller des gens non pas dans le but
de les poursuivre en justice mais dans
les buts de les empêcher d'exercer leur
liberté de manifester les autorités
elles se défendent de tout arrestation
injustifiée
dans ça n'existe pas dans notre pays
quand les forces de l'ordre interpellent
les individus c'est parce que ils ont
une suspicion forte voire ils les ont vu
commettre des infractions alors
évidemment on a un certain nombre de
fractions collectives comme le fait de
se constituer en groupe ment en vue de
commettre des violences qui est une
infraction que nous avons souvent on va
mettre en oeuvre donc évidemment il y a
des interpellations d'individus donc il
y a pas les interpellations préventives
ça n'existe pas selon le préfet de
police de Paris ces arrestations
serviraient à éviter les dégradations
Jean-François Mathieu c'est vous le
spécialiste quand même les chiffres
d'interpellation et le nombre est
impressionnant 258 à Paris lundi dernier
c'est énorme on peut on peut croire le
préfet quand il dit qu'il faut avoir
communé une exaction réellement si avant
d'être embarqué chacun connaît ici que
le code pénal il est assez comment dire
suffisamment compliqué pour laisser il y
a au moins trois dispositions et ces
sujets interprétations donc
effectivement si vous considérez que
ceux qui vont manifester qui en ont le
droit même si c'est un défilé pas
autorisé si vous considérez qui forme un
troublement et que pire encore c'est
pour aller à l'affrontement avec les
forces de l'ordre ou être violent vous
pouvez interpeller donc évidemment comme
il y a un flou
c'est assez curieux il faudrait et donc
c'est une interprétation est-ce que les
gens qui sont là ils viennent vraiment
pour manifester dans ce cas ils ont le
droit peu importe que ce soit autorisé
ou pas ce regroupement est autorisé et
voilà
c'est possible donc il suffit
effectivement à la police de dire bah
oui mais la manifestement leur tenue
leurs intentions les premiers
affrontements démontrent que ces gens-là
sont là pour ça et dans ce cas c'est
possible donc ça c'est le virer le code
pénal est construit ainsi mais au-delà
de ça ce qui est inquiétant dans les
temps qui viennent pour tout vous dire
c'est que si vous regardez ce qui s'est
passé pendant la période de gilet jaune
on peut tout à fait avoir pendant des
mois la même discussion que celle que
nous avons ici constaté à la fois
beaucoup de d'interpellations constater
un bilan humain lourd parce que je
rappellerai quand même dans l'épisode
gilet jaune il y a eu du coup quand même
un bilan qui était particulièrement
catastrophique de blesser même
d'ailleurs décès on a tendance à
l'oublier et si vous voulez ce qui a été
frappant dans le cas des gilets jaunes
c'est que enfin moi je n'avais jamais vu
à quel point on s'était accoutumer une
certaine manière à ce bilan ce qui fait
que
la même chose peut se produire tout
aussi facilement alors ça c'est ce qui
veut dire que ça peut durer alors que
dans le passé ce que je voulais dire
simplement c'est quand c'était on dit
toujours Malikou c'est qui en 1986 mais
il suffit à une époque il suffisait d'un
événement dramatique pour que on arrête
on en finisse ce qui est inquiétant
c'est que c'est plus vrai actuellement
nous avons sur parmi les manifestants ça
continuerait comment s'il y avait un
nouveau enfin je veux même pas imaginer
cette hypothèse mais on en est là c'est
pas impossible alors vous allez me dire
pendant les gilets jaunes c'était une
bavure peut-être une vieille dame etc
parce que je rappelle que c'est ce qui
s'est passé comment à Marseille à
Marseille voilà on peut dire c'est
malheureux c'est c'est dommage
collatéral et cette dame n'était pas une
jeune étudiante un jeune bon bref parce
qu'on sait très bien que l'émotion sera
pas la même mais malgré tout et donc
alors on sait qu'au barrage de Sivens
aurait là par contre c'était différent
non on peut pas conclure définitivement
s'il y avait un drame de ce type ça ne
déclencherait pas un pédalage et
l'abandon bien sûr d'une réforme comme
on l'a connu par le passé ce serait pas
la première fois mais c'est sans en
arriver jusque là on pouvait se épargner
en effet
tout à l'heure sur les trois qu'on a eu
il y a une période on a gâché une
occasion quand même enfin pardon mais
assez extraordinaire qui est que il y a
une inter syndicale qu'on n'a jamais
connue une mobilisation tout à fait
Pacifique iront avec les années qu'on a
connu on est en train de renouer avec ça
depuis 2016 c'était une occasion
historique quasiment d'en finir de
tourner la page de les affrontements des
Black Blocs de tout ça c'est raté
ils ont une responsabilité majeure il y
a des services d'Europe qui organisent
en lien avec un les forces de l'ordre
les manifestations
est-ce que vous allez être à la hauteur
de cette responsabilité pour éviter au
maximum ça dépend de responsabilité
c'est de sécuriser les cortèges et les
manifestants c'est ce qu'on fait c'est
ce qu'on continue à faire après on peut
pas tout sécuriser c'est pas notre
responsabilité d'ailleurs sinon ça
serait des milices privées donc après
c'est le travail des forces de l'ordre
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement joue une stratégie du
pourrissement qui est scandaleuse avec
des consignes scandaleuses qui sont
données aux forces de l'ordre parce que
leur a donné pour consignes par exemple
de faire des gardes à vue systématiques
de masse il y a des gens qui sont sortis
en jogging pour faire leur jogging qui
était sur le parcours de la
manifestation qui se sont fait
interpeller qui ont passé 24 heures en
garde à vue il y a des témoignages pour
dire ça la jeunesse aussi des gardes
défenseurs des droits à interpellé le
pouvoir le Syndicat de la magistrature
etc donc il y a des atteintes manifestes
aux libertés de défiler de s'organiser
moi ce soir je veux faire un appel
solennel au président de la République
la clé de la sortie de crise elle est
entre ses mains ce qu'il faut qu'il
fasse et qu'il ne promulgue pas cette
loi qui l'entende ce qui se passe dans
le pays qu'ils comprennent que si ils ne
retire pas cette loi il y aura pas de
retour à la normale on ne recommencera
pas à travailler comme avant que le pays
est un gouvernable si ne retire pas
cette réforme qui est illégitime
démocratiquement et injustifiée
économiquement
l'extension des grèves les personnels du
Mobilier national ce sont mises en grève
ils ont dit quoi ils ont dit que eux ils
refuseraient de faire leur travail et
donc ils refuseraient par exemple de
dérouler le tapis rouge pour la visite
du roi d'Angleterre qui est prévu les
jours à venir c'est un petit exemple
mais en fait dans tout le pays tous les
salariés ils refuseront de faire leur
travail normalement tant que cette
réforme n'est pas retirée le président
de la République dirigé le pays
ne retire pas c'est très fort il faut
qu'il entend le message allez le mot de
la fin Antoine Armand je crois
simplement qu'il faut pas tout mélanger
si vous voulez c'est à dire que bon
d'abord je rappelle qu'il y a quand même
eu un certain nombre de CRS et de
policiers qui ont été blessés y compris
grièvement qui sont à l'hôpital en ce
moment même aujourd'hui à cause
d'affrontement déclenché par une
manifestants et des bloqueurs
pour parler du maintien de l'ordre
qui sont qui se retrouvent à l'hôpital
parce qu'ils ont ils ont dû aller
débloquer une raffinerie je pense qu'il
y a ça
quand vous dites madame parce qu'il y a
des Black Blocs qui qui tapent sur les
policiers ou parce qu'il y a des
bloqueurs qui vont mettre des CRS à
l'hôpital que si on continue
c'est-à-dire si ces Black Blocs
continuent et bien c'est nous la
provocation et c'est nous qui devons
retirer la réforme vous mélangez tout et
c'est totalement inacceptable ensuite il
y a la question de l'apaisement les
services de d'ordre des syndicats ont je
crois on peut le reconnaître toujours
fait leur travail pris leur
responsabilité et font le maximum la
problème qu'on a moi je ne suis ni
Journaliste pour terminer policier le
problème qu'on a c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui des centaines d'individus
qui sont là pour en découdre pour faire
de la casse pour blesser les policiers
parfois les manifestants et ça c'est une
question éminemment délicate à gérer
pour les Français encore se retrouver
sur ce thème demain et la semaine
prochaine il y a le Conseil
constitutionnel aussi qui qui va rendre
son avis il est très très attendu
Emmanuel Macron à son corps
de sortie globale on en est pas du tout
là les sages planches rue de Montpensier
merci beaucoup merci merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat en direct vous
restez avec moi le remarquant je l'ai
dit dans une dizaine de minutes nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris ce soir
vous les voyez Mario Stasi de la lycra
va dresser le bilan de la semaine
d'action contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme à l'école l'oeil sur le
numérique de Delphine Sabatier retour
sur la folie
et puis dans Bourbon Express ce soir
tibohenoc nous raconte l'audition de
Marc-Olivier fauchel le patron de BFM TV
audition de la commission d'enquête sur
les ingérences étrangères mais d'abord
parlons un peu de vous Laurent marquant
jelly et du groupe horizon que vous
présidez à l'Assemblée horizon c'est le
parti d'Édouard Philippe qui compte 29
députés au Palais Bourbon il tient son
congrès ce week-end on en parle regardez
dans l'invitation d'elda mondagaba à
laquelle vous réagirez
si on vous invite Laurent marquant jelly
c'est parce que l'horizon politique
semble bien incertain la France traverse
une zone de turbulent Laurent marquant
Gély vous êtes ancien maire d'Ajaccio
député de Corse du Sud président du
groupe horizon à l'Assemblée nationale
horizon le parti fondé par l'ancien
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe libre
et loyal dont la majorité présidentielle
mais avec votre partenaire Renaissance
les relations ne sont pas au beau fixe
ces derniers mois début mars votre
groupe propose une loi pour instaurer
des peines minimales pour les délits
commis en récidive sur les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique le
groupe Renaissance votre compte
je pense que le groupe Renaissance a
tort aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans exception pour l'instant votre
appartenance à la majorité ne fait pas
de doute mais à un moment donné au fur
et à mesure que l'horizon 2027 va se
rapprocher il y aura la tentation de
prendre le large alors Laurent Marc
angélique libre et loyal mais jusqu'à
quand
et bah réponse alors marque angélique
jusqu'à quand jusqu'à la fin c'est quoi
la fin
des gens libres nous sommes loyaux
libres parce que nous avons notre
spécificité nous avons notre histoire
nous avons nos convictions loyaux parce
que ça nous caractérise et n'avons pas
l'intention de changer c'est pas un peu
la guerre froide avec Renaissance en ce
moment non non nous sommes au contraire
rassemblés nous l'avons démontré il y a
eu un vote de motion de censure après
nous avons une expression proposition de
loi contre proposition doit on sent
qu'il y a des animosité il y a des
différences ces différences elles sont
assumées nous avons voulu les assumer
dans le cadre notamment de la journée
niche parlementaire du groupe horizon il
arrive que parfois nous sommes pas
d'accord avec nos partenaires il arrive
et c'est la plupart des cas que nous
sommes d'accord et je pense que on parle
beaucoup de statistiques c'est ainsi il
y a même des sites Internet qui montrent
les statistiques regardez les
comparaisons de vote ou horizons et pas
forcément toujours en désaccord avec
Renaissance ou avec le modèle en
revanche je conçois que lorsque il
existe des différences alors faire
prendre beaucoup plus d'importance que
dans le nom vous trouvez qu'Edouard
Philippe a fait son maximum pour
soutenir le président sur les retraites
franchement
cette manière de présenter les choses
pour une bonne et simple raison c'est
Édouard Philippe on va pas faire mine de
découvrir sa manière de s'adresser aux
Français il ne s'exprime pas beaucoup et
je vais vous dire je pense qu'il a
raison je crois que à s'exprimer matin
midi et soir publié
il manque de poids lourds politiques on
est très peu entendu lorsque édou
Philippe s'est exprimé il l'a fait
devant des millions de téléspectateurs
sur une autre chaîne d'informations
BFMTV pour ne pas la nommer il l'a fait
et il a dit clairement son soutien cette
réforme et il a quelques amis à
l'Assemblée nationale dont je fais
partie qui ont été présents présents
durant les 15 jours d'examens à
l'Assemblée nationale présent lors du
vote de la motion de censure la semaine
dernière avec nos spécificités avec ce
que nous sommes mais nous avons soutenu
cette réforme quel est le principal
échec du Gouvernement sur ce texte vous
qui n'avez pas la langue de bois on l'a
entendu à la tribune vous pratiquer
l'autocritique qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché je crois d'abord que même quand
ça va bien et mieux il faut toujours se
remettre en question c'est une marque de
fabrique j'ai été comme cela était
rappelé tout à l'heure dans ce petit
reportage maire d'une ville de 72000
habitants j'ai été conseillé général
j'ai été conseillé régional je connais
la vie publique il faut se remettre en
question et je crois que au-delà de
l'activité politique je me permettrai
pas je me permettrai pas c'est
d'expérience de terrain
de nous rendre à une évidence vous avez
encore aujourd'hui des millions de gens
qui ont visiblement choisi de manifester
dans mes contentement par rapport à une
réforme vous avez des difficultés à
maintenir l'ordre public je crois que
rien n'est pire aujourd'hui que les
discours de déni de réalité d'un côté
comme de l'autre vous avez regardé
l'interview présidentielle hier ne
trouvez-vous pas
un manque d'empathie de la part du
président de la République dans la
manière dont finalement il a justifié
les choses sans finalement directement
s'adresser à ces Français qui souffrent
et on les entend tous les jours
d'abord ce que je pense c'est que
lorsqu'on est à la tête de l'État la
communication empathique est beaucoup
plus difficile que lorsque l'on est
maire lorsque l'on est parlementaire que
on est en printemps ou une représente
syndicale c'est beaucoup plus difficile
ensuite j'ai entendu hier tu as un
discours du président de la République à
sa forme de choses qui me tiennent à
cœur
le mot injustice a été prononcé et
l'action future du gouvernement sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République pour lutter contre certaines
formes d'injustice a été mentionnée et
je ne voudrais pas aujourd'hui qu'on
focalise uniquement sur les petits mots
sortis de leur contexte tournons-nous
vers l'avenir puisqu'il y a il a proposé
une nouvelle méthode moins de loi plus
de règlement qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
la loi doit pas être trop bavarde c'est
une conception que j'avais avant même
d'être parlementaire je suis juriste de
formation j'ai exacé à la profession
d'avocat il est vrai que nous sommes un
pays qui légifère beaucoup
et ensuite je crois qu'il faut peut-être
des lois qui soient davantage concertés
avec les oppositions
avec la majorité avec les partenaires
éventuels et l'idée de découper des
textes par exemple trois textes sur
l'immigration c'est un enterrement de
première classe je dirais pas que c'est
un enterrement de première classe en
tout cas je vais vous donner ma position
à titre personnel je pense qu'elle est
partagée par celles et ceux qui
m'accompagnent dans le groupe horizon
nous aurions souhaité des battre de ce
texte dans son entièreté je l'estimais
équilibré il y avait une partie
régularisation pour les travailleurs
étrangers il y avait une partie
régulation ce texte me semblait
équilibré je regrette à titre personnel
que nous ne puissions pas l'examiner
pour sortir de l'immobilisme Édouard
Philippe plaide pour un contrat de
coalition avec les républicains ils sont
pas discrédités les républicains quand
ni
ericsioti ni Olivier Marleix ne parvient
à assurer une majorité sur les retraites
alors qu'ils ont fait campagne sur les
65 ans le seul discrédit qui vaut dans
une démocratie c'est l'élection
et nous sommes élus depuis huit mois
maintenant pour
légiférer moi je dis et je le dis avec
Édouard Philippe depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois qu'effectivement la
situation politique dans laquelle nous
trouvons exige des réponses hors normes
avec qui on élargit avec qui on discute
une coalition législative chez LR avec
celles et ceux qui considèrent que le
pays ne peut pas être à l'arrêt avec eux
pourquoi pas mais moi j'aimerais aussi
allergie faire avec d'autres nous avons
démontré il y a eu un vote cette semaine
qu'on évoque pas beaucoup sur notre
politique nucléaire il y a 400 députés
plus de 400 députés qui ont voté pour le
projet de loi gouvernemental le passé à
réformer avec cette assemblée
aujourd'hui c'est que nous mettions pas
le pays à la raie ça a été rappelé je
pense que si demain nous arrêtons si
nous sommes dans l'abattement si nous
sommes dans l'immobilisme les Français
en paieront le prix et si nous ne
travaillons pas au service des Français
et bien nous aurons failli et à ce
moment-là la sanction le discrédit il
viendra des urnes il faut bien
construire ça peut pas être expert texte
vous y croyez comme ça il reste quatre
ans si vous n'avez pas un contrat clair
pour gouverner avec un allié ça tiendra
pas je réédite le fait de dire qu'une
coalition et la meilleure des solutions
le texte par textes ne suffit pas pour
l'instant ça ne marchait pas comment
vous expliquer qu'un tiers du groupe les
républicains et voter la censure c'est
un changement
j'y ai passé près de 20 ans j'étais au
RPR à l'UMP puis au Républicain ça
changement tout simplement parce que ce
parti politique aujourd'hui a changé
dans son implantation locale et puis je
crois qu'il y a aussi quelque chose
d'historique c'est un parti des sciences
Bonaparte soyez vous avec Alida Jacques
Chirac il y a une Nicolas Sarkozy et
depuis Nicolas Sarkozy ce parti n'a plus
le leader et je crois que pour un parti
d'essence bonapartiste comme les
républicains c'est un peu difficile à la
recherche d'un chef désespérément
parlons un peu du Congrès d'horizon qui
se tient ce week-end pourquoi refaire et
pour dire quoi mais pour réaffirmer nos
convictions et pour nous tenir à notre
objectif celui de rassembler à toujours
plus autour d'un certain nombre d'idées
autour d'une stratégie autour d'un
leader puisque il s'avère que à horizon
nous en avons un pour continuer
d'enraciner cette offre politique
nouvelle qui est jeune un an et demi
mais qui est déjà doté d'un groupe
Parlement aire l'Assemblée nationale de
plusieurs milliers de militants par de
la le pays et pour parler aussi du fond
lorsque nous voulons parler d'éducation
parce que nous voulons parler de
l'Europe parce que nous voulons parler
de la planète et de son avenir parce que
nous voulons parler aux Français de ce
qui les concerne vous allez réussir à
entretenir la flamme les nains Philippe
pour les Français il est encore très
populaire mais il reste il reste quatre
ans
la vie politique c'est un temps long et
nous nous considérons justement que être
otage du quotidien être otage de
l'immédiateté c'est pas bon être otage
également du manque de nuances c'est
aussi quelque chose de particulièrement
nocif donc nous sommes ambitieux nous
sommes ambitieux pour notre pays nous
sommes ambitieux pour la vie politique
de notre pays et nous allons continuer
de tisser ce lien Édouard Philippe a
avec les Français nous allons faire à
plusieurs parce que Édouard Philippe
n'est pas seul il sera candidat ça ça
lui appartient et en ce qui me concerne
je considère que sa place dans le débat
politique français elle est importante
importante aujourd'hui pour l'avenir
vous nous annoncez les petites surprises
pour terminer sur sur l'estrade du
Congrès horizon ce week-end ou pas des
invités nous aurons un des partenaires
qui nous rendront visite et j'espère
surtout que nous aurons de quoi parler
de fonds et d'être dans une forme de
nuance qui malheureusement je le vois
débat après débat manque malheureusement
et cruellement au débat public français
merci
de rester avec moi la photo de famille
de toutes les composantes de cette
majorité sera scruté pendant ce congrès
d'horizon à n'ont pas douter à laisser
l'heure d'accueillir à présent dans un
franchis pour leur partie prix ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite
bonsoir à vous les amis
carte blanche ce soir à Mario Stasi le
président de la lycra Delphine Sabatier
pour son oeil sur le numérique de
Bismarck bienvenue à vous deux mais on
commence comme chaque soir par le
bourbon Express qui nous est présenté ce
soir l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
Tibo inox à vous bonsoir à tous alors ce
soir je vais vous raconter la suite de
l'histoire du feuilleton commençait hier
ici à l'Assemblée l'affaire mbarquy
saison 2 alors après l'audition de l'ex
journaliste de BFM ce mercredi
aujourd'hui c'était au tour du patron de
la chaîne Marc-Olivier Fogiel d'être
entendu par les députés de la commission
d'enquête sur l'ingérence de puissance
étrangères alors je vous rappelle
l'effet Rachid mbar qui présentateur du
journal de la nuit sur BFM a été
licencié le mois dernier pour faute
grave par sa direction et lui reprochait
d'avoir présenté à l'antenne sans
validation par sa hiérarchie des images
et des informations
douteuses par exemple en faveur du
Royaume du Maroc d'un général soudanais
ou vantant les mérites d'un hôtel à des
informations sur lesquelles pèsent des
soupçons de manipulation certaines
pourraient avoir été commandités par une
officine israélienne spécialisée dans
l'influence pour le compte de clients
africains notamment le journaliste a été
auditionné hier il a nié toute
malhonnêteté voilà pour le résumé de la
saison 1 voilà pour les faits de cette
sidérante à faire qu'est-ce qu'on a
appris aujourd'hui alors Marc Olivier
Fogiel a précisé d'abord le nombre de
séquences incriminés 12 sur les deux
dernières années il a dit ça
stupéfaction en découvrant l'effet BFM
est une victime dans cette affaire
a-t-il déclaré le problème ce n'est pas
que ces informations étaient fausses un
ça le directeur général de la chaîne la
confirmé aujourd'hui le problème quoi
qu'en est dit Rachid M'Barki hier c'est
d'abord qu'il y avait un biais dans la
sélection de ces sujets mis à l'antenne
écoutez sur les 20h30 d'infos en continu
sur la chaîne ces informations
n'apparaissent que dans le cadre du
journal de la nuit aucun autre rédacteur
en chef journaliste présentateur de
tranche
va juger utile de relater ces
informations force de constater que elle
n'avait pas leur place à l'antenne et en
tout cas elle n'avait rien à voir avec
notre ligne éditoriale alors la question
qui se posait la suivante si ces
informations n'avaient pas leur place à
l'antenne comment un-t-elle pu y finir
et bien sur ce point Rachid Mbarki hier
a dit avoir agi en toute transparence
tout ce que j'ai fait était visible de
ma hiérarchie a-t-il dit s'il y a eu des
trous dans la raquette c'est qu'il n'y
avait pas je cite de process de
validation c'est ce qu'il a déclaré hier
alors évidemment Marc-Olivier Fogiel a
livré une toute autre version
aujourd'hui
nous avons des procédures robustes
l'intégralité des journaux sont validés
par un rédacteur en chef en amont ce qui
n'a pas été le cas dans les 12 séquences
dont on parle la validation
éditoriale n'a pas n'a pas été cet
arrangé pour être contourné c'était pas
des moments où il y a personne puisqu'il
y a toujours quelqu'un mais les
rédacteurs en chef sont sur plusieurs
tranches donc toujours quand le
rédacteur en chef était occupé à autre
chose pendant ce moment-là est toujours
en dernière minute les contusions de
l'audit ont donc montré craché la
liberté avait sciemment contourné les
processus internes alors il reste une
question est importante c'est c'est
l'argent il y a-t-il eu rétribution oui
alors hier Rachida dit n'avoir reçu
aucune rétribution pour la diffusion des
informations mises en cause il avait
confirmé sa source en revanche un
lobbyiste du nom de Jean-Pierre Duthion
aujourd'hui Marc-Olivier foget a déclaré
ne pas avoir d'éléments en montrant que
Rachida aurait pu être rétribué en
revanche Jean-Pierre Duthion aurait
proposé de l'argent à un autre
journaliste de BFM
ce que je sais dans le cadre de
l'en-tête interne en tout cas de
préciser un journaliste contacté après
le départ de Rachid m Barki il a été
contacté par Jean-Pierre Duthion et
Jean-Pierre Duthion lui a proposé une
rétribution contre une information qu'il
n'a pas jugé utile d'abord évidemment
pas la rétribution et l'information de
passer à l'antenne voilà Marc-Olivier
Fogel qui a déclaré en revanche n'avoir
pas d'informations sur le fait que cette
affaire puisse relever ou non d'une
tentative d'ingérence d'une puissance
étrangère ce sera la justice de le
déterminer a-t-il bien sûr il y a une
procédure en cours merci pour ce point
complètement Laurent Marc Angéli elle
est édifiante cette affaire s'il y a des
soupçons c'est ce ne sont que des
soupçons mais tout de même elle est
complexe déjà vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure hors caméra il y a des termes
que beaucoup de nos compatriotes ne
comprennent pas il y a une enquête
parlementaire qui vise à déterminer s'il
y a des influences étrangères pour
influencer sur la formation il y a déjà
une décision qui été prise à savoir
sanctionner l'entreprise savoir BFM à
sanctionner le journaliste ça c'est une
première chose il aura à se défendre ou
pas pour faute grave et là aussi la
justice aura à le dire après vous avez
des soupçons de d'intervention et il y a
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
qui a été demandé par le rassemblement
national qui est en train d'enquêter
là-dessus qui est incroyable c'est la
vulnérabilité maintenant de notre pays
dans plein de domaines sur des
ingérences on a vu avec la Russie là
c'est Israël on a l'impression que
rien rien n'est vraiment
suffisamment solide pour être protégé de
ça mais c'est pour ça que moi en ce qui
me concerne je fais partie de celles et
de ceux qui pensent que le droit à
l'information est très important dans
notre pays et que nous devons pouvoir
compter sur des femmes et des hommes qui
exercent ce métier ce journaliste
notamment de manière déontologique et de
manière propre ensuite effectivement
nous voyons nous le voyons aujourd'hui
la désinformation sur les réseaux
sociaux mais également par ailleurs peut
parfois être présente allez on enchaîne
avec Mario Mario Stasi président de la
lycra vous vouliez revenir cette semaine
sur la semaine de l'éducation et
l'action contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme dans les écoles vastes
chantier immense même quel est le bilan
on sait que les professeurs ont des
outils mais sont-ils adaptés
merci à Myriam le constat est simple les
carences sont nombreuses lorsqu'on
l'évoque par exemple l'antisémitisme
dans les programmes on commence avec
l'affaire Dreyfus et on termine par le
paroxysme nazi on réduit ainsi ce fléau
pourtant multimillénaire un racisme
entre guillemets dont on ignore
l'origine la nature profonde et les
dynamiques historiques et qui conduit
ensuite sans trop savoir pourquoi au
crime de génocide silence ou presque
dans les programmes sur les racines
religieuses chrétiennes ou musulmanes de
ce mépris de cette haine du juif dont
l'antisionisme radical et la forme la
plus actuelle les élèves n'accèdent donc
pas au concept ni au références
historiques qui leur permettraient de
comprendre la longévité de cette vidéo
phobie donc toute une série de zones
d'ombre elle ne concerne que
l'antisémitisme ou pas non il en va de
même avec l'appréhension du racisme dit
de couleur à travers des périodes ou des
crimes spécifiques esclavage la
colonisation ou l'aparté de sud-africain
par exemple exemple comment les élèves
peuvent-ils construire une réflexion
pertinente sur la continuité historique
avec ces ruptures et ses permanences
comment peuvent-ils comprendre le
présent et ses spécificités les
phénomènes actuels de repli identitaires
les blancs les noirs les musulmans les
juifs ils usent eux-mêmes dans le
langage courant de catégories qui
consolide des formules racialisantes la
seule étude des grands récits
traumatiques permet difficilement aux
élèves d'analyser les préjugés
d'analyser les mécanismes à l'oeuvre
dans le monde actuel dans leur entourage
sur les réseaux sociaux ou encore dans
leur club sportifs alors que faut-il
faire dans l'éducation selon vous et
bien sans doute envisagez une approche
générale du racisme et de
l'antisémitisme qui réintroduirait le
temps long dans l'analyse de ces
phénomènes qui souligneraient leur
ressort commun tout en les singularisant
globaliser et comparer pour éviter tout
appropriation ou déformation victimaires
montrez aussi que les luttes
antiracistes ont une quoi et que
l'engagement actuel ne peut être
confisqué ni même privatisé par des
adeptes du racialisme la figure d'un
Gaston monerville par exemple qui
s'engagea constamment tout au long du
20e siècle pour défendre l'égalité en
droit et en cite et en dignité des
citoyens et noirs et juifs témoignent de
la transversalité des luttes
antiracistes formées enfin véritablement
nos enseignants sur ces questions afin
qu'il répondent aux nombreuses
interrogations de leurs élèves comment
se fabrique au cours des siècles et les
imaginaires ratiaux et les idéologies
racistes comment les préjugés anti Juifs
se réactualisent au fil de l'histoire et
conservant leur potentiel meurtrier les
élèves comprendraient ainsi que la
prétendue identité raciale n'est pas un
héritage qu'ils doivent subir ou
cultiver mais bien le fruit de faible
savante pétrit de croyances de mythes et
de préjugés il faut en définitive
réarmer les enseignants pour nourrir la
conscience de l'élève citoyen pour
nourrir le sentiment universaliste chez
tous les élèves et il y a du boulot
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire merci
pour cette belle carte blanche et là
lycra complètement investi dans dans
cette mission y compris dans les écoles
on termine avec vous Delphine Delphine
Sabatier vous lui revenir sur cette vie
pity vous nous en aviez déjà parlé mais
vous dites attention il y a un
emballement autour de ce petit robot
d'intelligence artificielle il y a un
phénomène chatipiti c'est de la folie
mais clairement là c'est un emballement
mais c'est une précipitation c'est
absolument fou l'accélération dans le
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
générative vous l'avez vu hier soir sur
les réseaux sociaux tout le monde s'en
en parle on aime bien jouer avec ses Ia
qui permettent de générer à peu près
tout et n'importe quoi et alors on a
plein de entre guillemets clones de chat
GPT qui arrive comme ça dans une course
effrénée il y a un exemple étonnant
quand même Google Google grand manitou
de l'intelligence artificielle vous
savez saisir qui battaient les champions
d'échecs du jeu de Go et ben il se
retrouve dans la précipitation a
complètement raté le lancement de barde
Sonia concurrente de chat gptt parce que
fallait il y avait tout de suite aller
se précipiter puis il y a meta aussi
alors là c'est quand même assez dingue
Mark Zuckerberg qui nous a expliqué il y
a pas très longtemps qu'il allait tout
miser sur les méta verres jusqu'à
changer le nom de son groupe facebook en
méta et bien là d'un coup la priorité
des priorités c'est l'intelligence
artificielle donc encore les gars femme
que l'on retrouve derrière toutes ces
avancées toujours les mêmes géants du
numérique américain avec en embuscade la
Chine et l'absence des Européens donc
c'est ce qui vous inquiète ça alors
c'est pas bon c'est vrai qu'on a pas
envie de rester dans ce monde inféodé au
service numérique américain mais c'est
pas la seule chose qui m'inquiète moi je
voudrais qu'on pointe l'absence de
règles en fait on a entre les mains un
outil extraordinairement puissant sans
aucun garde alors on peut se rassurer en
se disant que on est face à des
perroquets stupides comme nous l'a dit
le ministre du numérique Jean-Noël
Barrault mais qui peut prédire
aujourd'hui des conséquences du saut
technologique qu'on est en train de
vivre c'est intéressant d'ailleurs
l'épouvantail qu'agide Luc Ferry dans le
Figaro il écrit ça donne le sentiment
qu'on se rapproche d'une machine
consciente d'elle-même sentiment
absolument trompeur donc ça montre à
quel point il est nécessaire justement
de clarifier les choses alors hier vous
montriez les dérapages ces deep fake
c'est fake news avec les images
notamment
c'est toute la valeur de l'écrit de
l'image qui est en train de s'écrouler
on a une dangereuse confusion aussi
entre ce qui est produit par la machine
et par l'homme le statut de création des
auteurs tout ça c'est en train d'être
remis en cause on est face à une arme
informationnelle et culturelle sans
précédent sans doute aussi une fracture
sociale le haut-commissaire aux droits
de l'homme de l'ONU
juju que c'est les droits fondamentaux
humains qui sont menacés gravement
menacées qu'il nous faut des garde-fous
efficaces alors les concepteurs même de
ces intelligences artificielles ils nous
disent ah oui non mais allez-y il nous
faudrait un peu des cadres éthiques
allez-y travailler dessus parce qu'on en
a besoin sauf que pendant ce temps il
continue à développer à marche forcée et
en règle toujours un train de retard
ces produits qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour
te mettre en place ce cadre voilà et ben
voilà la pelle est lancée vous avez déjà
essayé d'amour
j'ai vu que des collègues avaient déposé
un amendement hier sur le projet de loi
sur les jeux olympiques le groupe lyaute
par l'intelligence artificielle en tout
cas merci pour cette alerte il est temps
de réguler avant que ce soit trop tard
c'est j'ai bien compris merci à vous les
affranchis merci Laurent marquant j'ai
dit merci de nous avoir accompagné ce
soir tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire Jean-Pierre Gratien à
demain
[Musique]